all right welcome to this busy news
breaking edition of Hannity reporting
tonight from California were out on the
west coast and tonight we have breaking
news on multiple fronts
in just moments Senator Lindsey Graham
he will join us to respond to Susan Rice
calling him a piece of bleep but we
start in the Washington swamp where
House Republicans they are today
fighting back against this corrupt
secret behind closed doors smoke-filled
room Venezuela style impeachment coup
attempt just hours ago group of
lawmakers literally stormed into yet
another top-secret session of the
corrupt Adam shifts kangaroo court and
once again the cowardly corrupt ship the
lying Adam Schiff well he was sent to
hold yet another secret impeachment
hearing with secret testimony recorded
only by a secret transcript Republicans
can't even see it unless they have a
democratic minder but then the corrupt
ship well he immediately halted the
session when Republican lawmakers
entered the room now let this be a very
clear warning to chef and Pelosi and
Democrats everywhere
well the secret Soviet style and
Pietschmann coup attempt this cannot
stand
we do have a constitution we do have
precedents we do have something called
due process Republicans who value their
Constitution and the sovereignty of the
American people this is a fight worth
fighting and injustice worth overturning
and by the way every step of the way
every room in the US Capitol Republicans
ought to have a right to be there
the president's attorneys have a right
to be there that's why it's illegitimate
and unconstitutional they are rightly
tonight demanding transparency due
process basic fairness equal justice and
an answer to a very simple question well
what does the corrupt Adam Schiff have
to hide let's take a look what does that
have shift trying to hide I think that's
a question so many people have so many
my colleagues have so many people in the
press should have is through those
hidden closed doors over there Adam
Schiff is trying to
to impeach a president of the United
States voting members of Congress are
being denied access from being able to
see what's happening behind these closed
doors now it's obvious the corrupt
cowardly Adam Schiff he doesn't want you
the American people to know the whole
truth he doesn't want you to watch this
kangaroo court process nothing could be
further from the truth when he says oh
yeah we really want to be transparent
now this so-called impeachment inquiry
is one big corrupt hoax one big massive
lie and by the way coming up tonight
lawmakers who did in fact take the right
step in storm shifts top secret session
today they will join us with more
details let's be clear we've said it a
million times and I'll say it again
congressman Adam Schiff is not
trustworthy we know he is a pathological
liar he lied about having top secret
evidence at Trump Russia collusion he
promised that to us for two and a half
years he lied when he said that evidence
of collusion was right there in plain
sight no it wasn't he lied about not
having any prior contact with the non
whistleblower hearsay whistleblower and
we know now that his office in fact had
contact with the whistleblower and we
believe was given advice from his office
that would make him and people in his
office material witnesses in this case
it doesn't get any more corrupt and
that's the real reason that he doesn't
want this whistleblower to testify well
if that happened he would likely be
exposed as having been a part of this
whole entire setup and by the way let's
not forget one other thing big lie Adam
Schiff he lied about the transcript of
trumps phone call with Ukraine in fact
that guy the corrupt shift' read a
completely fictional transcript into the
record during an official hearing this
guy lies over and over again because the
truth does not fit what is a warped
vengeful rage induced psychotic
anti-trump narrative of his there was no
collusion there was no quid pro quo we
have the transcript we don't need
hearsay whistleblowers we don't care
except what he did
wrong he should have been honest about
it you know we really don't care about
the Sham hearings he's running what he's
gonna come out of a hearing you don't
let Republicans in you just selectively
leaked that which is favorable to you
you won't even let Republicans see the
entire transcript unless they have a
Democratic staffer a minder go in that
is their job they too have due process
rights the president's attorney yet they
should be in the room every single time
now the president was freely and fairly
elected an electoral college landslide
and ever since he has been elected he's
been faithfully executing his sworn duty
to the Constitution into this country
one of those sworn duties detailed
article two section three of the United
States Constitution requires that the
president uphold the laws of the land
well that would include Ukraine election
interference in 2016 that would include
Biden using taxpayer dollars 1 billion
taxpayer dollars shaking down Ukraine to
get a prosecutor fired who we now know
was investigating his son the same son
who had no experience with gas energy
oil or the country of Ukraine no
experience if being paid millions of
dollars prosecutors investigating him
Joe says you got six hours six hours
you're not getting the money unless you
fire that prosecutor we now know that
was investigating his son so that sounds
to me like they were trying to buy favor
and goodwill from the Biden's why on
earth would you pay a kid that had no
experience he's not a kid he's 49 years
old why would you pay the son of a vice
president millions of dollars when he
has zero experience in anything related
to Ukraine or energy this was why it's
so critically important that the
administration and Republicans in
Congress do their job get to the bottom
of all of this on top of what we have
identified as the single biggest abuse
of power corruption scandal and modern
American political history now we have
an update the Inspector General's Pfizer
report well we know it's
finished it still not been released to
the public now we've seen delay after
delay after delay after delay now why
well Senator truck Grassley of Iowa Iowa
tweeted quote well all of the delays and
all the excuses why the Horowitz IG
Pfizer report is in public yet after
several months of anticipation well that
it leads me to be suspicious it's going
to be deep six by the deep state tonight
I don't know why the findings are not
yet public I'm as angry as everybody
else because we already know what
happened we know there was premeditated
fraud on a FISA Court because we know
the bulk of information was the Hillary
Clinton bought and paid for dirty
Russian dossier oh so they could help
her get elected in 2016 and by the way
what did we learn from that that they
never verified it and it was
unverifiable that would mean the deep
state is protecting their own we will
find out eventually we need to get to
the truth now I'm told the first week in
November I guess I shouldn't hold my
breath now thankfully investigative
reporter John Solomon he'll join us in a
few minutes with positive news about the
Pfizer report he also has other breaking
new details about the origins of the
Russia witch-hunt
now that investigation is being led by
US Attorney John Durham and it's now
ongoing and it is now expanding in size
and scope because of new explosive
evidence tonight Fox News is reporting
that this brand new evidence was
uncovered during a recent trip to Rome
with the Attorney General Bill Barr he
was there dorms been there now keep in
mind this probe is focused on whether or
not the powerful tools of our
intelligence community were weaponized
against you we the American people and
people associated with and affiliated
with the Trump campaign and whether or
not Intel officials at the highest
levels to circumvent US law we're out
we're outsourcing surveillance against
innocent Americans by other countries in
other words they're getting their
friends and the Intel community in Italy
and Australia and great
written to do things they couldn't do
legally here okay well that would make
you guilty of circumventing the laws
both countries are now fully cooperating
with the door and probe we can report
that tonight and according to a report
from the Washington Examiner
we now have identified four notorious
deep state figures are now wrapped up up
to their eyeballs in this investigation
including Obama CIA Chief John Brennan
Obama's Director of National
Intelligence James clapper fired FBI
agent guy in the middle of all of it
Peter struck also the author of Hillary
Clinton's dirty Russian dossier that
would be Christopher Steele himself this
is big news tonight and now the wall
seemed to finally be caving in and we're
going to get to the truth now what are
these four men what do they all have in
common no one they all possess a rage
and psychotic hatred for all things
Donald Trump and too they should all be
very very nervous tonight because US
Attorney John Durham the Attorney
General Bill Barr they are pushing to
get to the truth one other good sign
that Durham and his investigation is
gaining serious traction you got
Brennan's current colleague MS TNC that
would be area 51 Roswell Rachel Maddow
MS DNC trying to spin upcoming findings
they know it's gonna be bad with a brand
new conspiracy theory see they were
peddling conspiracy theories lies
propaganda misinformation wrong day
after day week after week month after
month and it went on for years and now
they're trying to prepare themselves for
the when the real truth is coming out
let's take a look it really does seem
like they are going to use the power of
the US Justice Department to help them
make that case that the Democrats are
the real source of the scandal here with
what Bar and Durham appear to be doing
here to try to boost the president's
campaign they are crossing a bit of a
Rubicon in terms of what the US
government is for and part of what we're
gonna figure out when this is all over
it's how we cross back over it
ah now after two two plus years two and
a half years of lies they're back at it
more conspiracy theories more lies more
speculation zero facts there you have an
area 51
Roswell Rachel Maddow at it again when
will they ever learn they don't care
about learning for them it's an agenda
for them it's about all things Democrat
for then it's get rid of Trump any way
we can
truth well that doesn't matter to her or
anyone else frankly on that network but
still someone might want to remind NBC's
chief conspiracy theorists that US
Attorney John Durham is an investigator
long respected by both sides of the
aisle in fact he was previously
appointed by two Democratic attorney
generals to investigate highly sensitive
cases remember Janet Reno well she
selected Durham to investigate corrupt
law enforcement officials and their
dealings with notorious gangster Whitey
Bulger Eric Holder appointed Durham
himself to lead the DOJ investigation
into the use of enhanced interrogation
techniques and dorms ongoing
investigation now into the origins of
the rush of witch-hunt is not a
political stunt it's a very real probe
about real abuses of power what happened
in 2016 and beyond if this continues to
happen you don't have a constitution you
don't have rule of law you don't have
equal justice under the law and you
don't have equal application of our laws
and there's got to be a reckoning in the
deep state because if they keep doing
this they'll get you six ways but Sunday
Chuck Schumer said we're gonna lose
those constitutional protections that we
thought we had in this country now also
breaking tonight investigative reporter
John Solomon we go back to him he has
brand new evidence that commis FBI knew
that the dirty Russian dossier was
garbage they knew it but they used it
anyway to willfully deep fraud a FISA
Court and obtained a warrant to spy on
the Trump campaign associate by the name
of Carter page which gave him a backdoor
into all things Trump war
that would be the Trump campaign
transition and presidency